because i said in the book you talk
about how the kind of rivalry between
managers so who was your biggest kind of
rival bet noir what would it be alex
ferguson
he was my biggest rival yes for 10 years
and because they had
is shouting oh yes me there yeah yeah
you look like you're you're just like
zoning out
is he going i want my mars bars
where are the mars bars
i look like somebody who didn't get the
master
yeah you look like oh i forgot to get
mars
but was it really kind of properly
aggressive with him or was it just kind
of
no you're playing your role you know
competition
uh andrew could tell you that is real
it's it's you or me because jose
mourinho i notice you don't mention them
in the book
no now this are you actually having
fisticuffs here
because that's a really pathetic looking
fight
you don't like you granted colin first
in bridgeton's diary
no you you tell your prayers you have
always to be in control of what you do
but
sometimes you don't manage to do it do
you remember what you were fighting
about
yeah yeah was it football no
we didn't talk a lot it was just a
physical there
and that's it was uh basically uh
me losing control oh did you start that
fight
i start that yeah
oh
can you can give me the yellow card now
pick a side or the red event
you